astronomers always discovering something
new something unexpected I have every
expectation that gravitational
observatories will see something funny
and that'll send fear is scurrying to
explain
[Music]
and so if you've got one of these laser
interferometers with the arms that are
perpendicular and the wave comes through
it's going to stretch one and shrink the
other
now this is where it gets really
fascinating because we work out the
strength of a typical gravitational wave
from an in spiral of two black holes in
in a nearby Galaxy or something like
that how much is that movement and the
answer is it's equivalent to the width
of a human hair in the distance to the
nearest star I mean isn't that
staggering so you've got this
interferometer these things are
kilometers in size and the light goes
back and forth so many times and they've
got you know huge mirrors weighing more
than a person and they can detect the
motion of a mirror like that the the
mirror itself moves less than the
nucleus of an atom so that is really
cutting edge technology I got interested
in this stuff in the late 70s I wrote a
book on it called the turtle gravity
waves back in 1980 and I never thought
in my life I would see these things
detected but in 2015 Bingo the first
gravitational wave event was detected a
pair of black holes in a galaxy I think
1300 light years away
36 roughly 30 something solar masses
these black holes uh spiral together and
collided and so this was uh you know
Triumph of Technology but an incredible
indication because it was nearly 100
years after Einstein had predicted that
there exists gravitational waves a
hundred years a lot of people thought
well are they really there but sure
enough they are and uh there was a lot
of fanfare but it wasn't very long
before they saw another event and then
another event another event so on and
this is now uh established itself in the
last few years as a new branch of
astronomy so having got these amazing
instruments that can detect
gravitational waves
um what what are they good for well I've
already mentioned the in spiral of black
holes and neutron stars and there was
one extraordinary event a few years ago
where two neutron stars came together
and collided and the gravitational
bursts of waves from that was detected
at the same time as a satellite detected
a flash of gamma rays
and then there were there were Optical
measurements as well and so it was uh
clever people figured out that the
coalescence of these two neutron stars
which very violent event created uh a
large number of elements particularly
the element gold and so this called
people's imagination more gold was made
in that microsecond that those two
neutron stars
um merged together and if the entire
Earth was made of gold if more than an
Earth's mass worth and so
um that is part of the story of the
origin of the elements in the universe
and this can not only be studied just as
that one burst but in Australia there's
a proposal for a system called Nemo
which if I remember stands for Neutron
extreme matter Observatory which would
drill into the fine details of that
because when those two neutron stars
collide they recreate in a in a
microcircuit the conditions that would
have prevailed very early on in the Big
Bang so you're sort of doing experiment
not experimental but observational
physics of one of the earliest epochs of
the universe and you need the
gravitational signature of that to be
able to see exactly what is happening
with those neutron star coalescences but
I started by saying that we might be
able to hear the Big Bang as well as see
the flash from it uh and there it's a
very different story because
uh the Big Bang was a long time ago the
universe has expanded a lot since and um
the rumble if you like of that uh
primordial exposure and that Rumble the
the gravitational waves have been
stretched by the expansion of the
universe so they're now sort of huge but
there's a proposal uh to send an
interferometer into space well
constructed in space is called Lisa
laser
something or other
and it will be mirrors which will be
like millions of kilometers apart and it
will be an interferometer in space so
we'll be able to detect uh gravitational
waves of extremely long wavelengths like
those coming from The Big Bang so that's
the next step in this technology
and the other just general points is
that every time there's been an advance
in astronomy with the instruments uh the
first of all the optical telescope then
the radio telescope and then all the
other you know the satellites detect
X-rays and gamma rays and so on
astronomers always discover something
new something unexpected and so I have
every expectation that gravitational
observatories will will see something
funny
going on what's that you know that we
never expected that this funny signature
these waves with these peculiar
properties
um and that'll send theorists scurrying
to explain that's a new type of object
out there in space or a new type of
physical phenomenon there's one that
some colleagues of mine get excited by
you may have heard of string theory
about uh super strings everything's made
out of strings there are other types of
strings not those strings cosmic strings
these would be like threads that would
have been produced just after the big
bang they're like uh almost knots in the
in the fields that permeate the Universe
um but one-dimensional and these would
be long threads maybe forming Loops it's
maybe stretching right across the
universe and they they wriggle around
like this prolific source of
gravitational waves so if there are
cosmic strings out there during their
wriggle then that that will produce very
distinctive types of gravitational waves
and then there's one last thing I can't
resist mentioning because um um
a lot of young people find all this
stuff really exciting and an
undergraduate she's just beginning so
she'd be like 18. she uh emailed me to
say I'm really excited by the work
you're doing and can I do a project with
you and so we sat down and I said well
what are you interested in she said well
gravitational waves and I'm also
interested in wormholes well wormholes
are like black holes but different
because in a black hole it's a one-way
journey to know where you fall in and
you don't come out again a wormhole has
an exit as well as an entrance so it's
sort of superficially it's a massive
object and you fall in but you go
through and you come out somewhere else
and those of you old enough to remember
the movie contact will remember you know
what a wormhole looks like as Jody
Foster filmed through one and it's it's
like going on the London Underground and
you come out you come out somewhere else
uh
very hypothetical I happen to have just
come from a conference in Rome with
Roger Penrose who will be talking here
tomorrow and that was all about
wormholes and do they really exist and
could you turn them into time machines
and so on and that's all very
fascinating and highly speculative but
but this uh this young lady uh is
interested in what would be the
gravitational wave signature from
wormholes so basically a wormhole
swallows a black hole it's a look it's
in the throat of this thing and spits it
out the other side or maybe two
wormholes spiral together hit each other
you know what what would um what would
that be like what type of gravitational
wave signature so she asked me this I
said well I haven't a clue
um but it turns out that that also this
Rome conference was Kip Thorne who just
got the Nobel Prize uh I think last year
for gravitational waves he was with the
like the driving force behind the laser
gravitational wave into parameters but
he was also the architect of this whole
Wormhole Theory because he developed the
theory of wormholes because Carl Sagan
who who wrote a famous astronomer wrote
the wrote the book contact on which the
movie was based and anyone who likes
science fiction will know how boring it
is that it takes so long to get to
another another star system you know
thousands of years at present rocket
speed but even light would take me you
know many many years to go between Star
systems wouldn't it be handy if you had
something like a Stargate or a shortcut
that could get us from Earth to the
other side of the Galaxy you know in a
few minutes rather than having to wait
take millions of years to fly there so
it was a science fiction idea but he
asked kepthon at the California
Institute of Technology to check it out
so Kip and his students said well you
know maybe if you did this did that you
could actually make a wormhole and they
soon realized if you could make the
Wormhole could be turned into a time
machine so I'm so very much off topic
the point being that this one man is the
world expert at wormholes and the world
expert on gravitational waves I said to
him Kip
my undergraduate student has asked me to
ask you what would be the gravitational
wave signature from a wormhole and he
said I have the clue
so that's that that's an open question
um so we'll we'll see how how she gets
on with her project
from our debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV